new in theaters this weekend Bohemian
Rhapsody nobody's fool and the
Nutcracker and the four realms what will
you see this is your weekend ticket can
you do the fandango freddie mercury and
the members of queen can this is a
well-known fact that it's just a
different iteration of the Macarena it's
just basically that in Reverse you start
from the head and you end up on the hips
you come out different dances by our
movement coaches Bohemian Rhapsody comes
out this weekend this epically musical
biography follows Freddie Mercury and
his little-known band Queen on their
journey to music stardom I dare you to
watch this without singing along or
stomping your feet to the music it will
rock you this movie is for you if you
love the music of Queen one of the
greatest bands of all time musical
biopics strike a chord with you or
you're as impressed as much as I am by
how much Ramy Malick looks like Freddie
Mercury Tyler Perry Whoopi Goldberg and
Tiffany Haddish me ready also in
theaters this weekend nobody's fool
Lamas Anika put me out this connection
is so reckoning hello mama
you know I'm sorry what we not all know
cell phone line I can't hear you baby I
can't his mama mama
when Tiffany's character Tania is
released from prison she looks to her
much more put-together sister for help
during the transition back to normal
life turns out Danica's life might not
be as put together as they both thought
if the man looks too good to be true
we're pretty sure that the guy who
talked to isn't real this movie is for
you if you love anything Tyler Perry you
love anything Tiffany Haddish
or you've ever had a boyfriend that
turned out to be catfishing you with
Halloween out of the way the holiday
season is finally here
what better movie to kick off the season
with then the Nutcracker and the four
realms mother Jinja started this war
don't you know it's dangerous here I
hope you'll be the one to finish it this
reimagining of the classic holiday story
the Nutcracker in the Mouse King is an
impressive fantasy adventure featuring
Keira Knightley as sugarplum fairy this
movies for you if you're a fan of Keira
Knightley you're a fan of the classic
Nutcracker story or like me you can't
wait to get those holiday sweaters out
of the closet sit by the fire with a
warm cup of cocoa coincidentally cocoa
is available on Fandango now that is
your weekend ticket what will you see
check back next week for the return of
The Grinch
[Music]